das war ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit hi
ich bin Marie das ist mein Gewächshaus
und ich versuche das Obst und Gemüse für
meine Familie komplett selber anzubauen
das vor kurzem haben in meinem
Gewächshaus noch Enten gewohnt jetzt
muss das aber schnell frei werden weil
dringend die Tomaten in die Erde müssen
eigentlich pflanze ich die schon Mitte
April jetzt ist es bald Ende Mai und ich
muss dringend dringend das Gewächshaus
mitmachen damit das überhaupt noch was
wird mit der Tomatenernte irgendwie
waren ständig so viele andere Sachen
entweder an der Arbeit oder in der
Familie dann sind wir krank geworden und
in solchen Momenten ärgere ich mich so
weil das Gärten an den Kopf eigentlich
so schön frei macht im Alltag Stress und
so schöner Ausgleich ist aber wenn man
immer hinterher hängt mit seinen
Aufgaben dann wird das dazu dass das
gerne auf einmal zu einem riesigen
Stressfaktor wird und das ist so schade
ich sage das jetzt zu mir und zu allen
anderen Leuten da draußen denen es
genauso geht es ist völlig okay mal
einen Termin abzusagen einfach nur um
Zeit im Garten zu verbringen